eventually at the end of the day
we are making sure that
uh the end user will get a more secure
product
and and this is what excites me the
understanding that
if we would do right and and if we would
walk
uh in the right way and we do the right
things inside of the product the impact
can impact billions of people out there
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community community-driven vc fund in
silicon valley in partnership with
lumitec sponsored by homeward ventures
hippo insurance oppos labs synergy
global hillel at stanford leap
birthright excel serona partners and in
media partnership with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders meet guy fletcher the co-founder
and ceo of cider security
guy has a rich 18 plus years of
background of cyber security and
management expertise with vast
experience in sas and apsack an aif
major retired guy held the position of
apps flyer ciso for three years prior to
founding cider and before that worked
for lifeperson as part of the security
team
guy fletcher welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for joining me
today how are you
i'm doing great thank you for hosting me
and inviting me to to participate in
this great uh podcast thank you thank
you for joining me from the from the
cider security offices and another
exciting episode talking to an
entrepreneur in a really exciting space
today looking at security teams and i
love the headline on your website
security at the pace of engineering and
something that is definitely not
happening today in the world
it's something that needs to happen a
very ambitious goal we'll talk about
that in a second and but so guy well
let's start with you know you as an
entrepreneur you've done some incred
incredible things before
previously you were information security
team lead at live person you were
information security consultant and
comsec but most recently uh the cso and
dpo of apps flyer a company that we all
know of course and are very proud of so
some fantastic positions across the
ecosystem the transition to becoming a
ceo what what is that about for you
uh you can say you i moved to the dark
side of 100
but i think that
i you can say that i've been in the
uh
cyber trenches uh for almost 20 years uh
before the consultant before the live
person i also have been part in the
many years in the israeli air force in
the cyber uh security teams uh
so i grew up for almost 20 years in
different positions in the in the in the
trenches of security
and then you know after a few years as a
cso and dpo at uh
ups flyer when i
part of my
a lot of my time
almost day to day i met with
startup with entrepreneurs and and i was
really excited about helping them and
and working with them and supporting
them and i think that apps flyer has
been
an amazing ground for a lot of great
startup
startups to grow
and
after a few years i
took a decision that
i need to do this jump i know it's not a
trivial jump for a lot of people that
again to go out from the comfort zone of
as of cisco and you know and organize
the place and and everything
but i felt that
uh the opportunity is there uh the time
is is for me is on a personal level is
uh is uh this is the right time
and also
i felt that so let's let's let's delay
on this point for just a second guys
yeah the right time what does that mean
the right time for you why
why is now the right time for you to
start a company i mean i understand why
for a lot of people that are you know
straight out of the army 23 24 year olds
you know not much to lose you know
you're you're a little you have more
experience a little bit older you've
seen more you have many more
opportunities than the average you know
person in the tech ecosystem why is not
the right time
uh there are it's a combination of a few
things
first of all my maturity level
the fact that
i'm much more
grown up
as
a person as a person inside the cyber
security industry you know i seen
everything uh i i by the way part of my
uh uh
day to day is try to solve the problems
that i experience
in my day-to-day in my
when i was a cso when i was a security
team in part of the security team those
are the problems that i'm trying to
solve
and in addition to that i feel that
you know we are in
crazy time
for building a company and and you know
with uh
also from an ecosystem perspective the
adoption of sas companies and you know
it's becoming more more uh
uh uh
easy to consume easy to to
adopt so i think we are in a very
different area
uh than we were like before by the way
uh you know so so
a good thing about the corona before
corona time it was a different uh
time and now it's uh it's good for
company to as a sas company to be
and also from a person a message but
maybe it's also only from personal
perspective but today
as entrepreneurship as entrepreneur uh
uh
the ability to balance family and work
is much
uh
better than before
now you know we meet with hundreds of
people
on a monthly basis without leaving our
amazing office here in tel aviv or
leaving the house that we can meet and
we can balance
the life that we have and as a father of
three amazing uh
three princes i want to be with them so
i think it's a combination of many stuff
that
happened and and
helped me to take a decision uh to to do
this uh uh uh jump into this uh
new position and completely new life
all right
let's jump into the security world you
know you have a lot of experience in the
security space as you mentioned so
obviously you've felt you've mentioned
that you've felt a lot of these problems
firsthand and that serves as part of the
inspiration for the work that you're
doing today
cider what what is the cider you know
that comes right before the security
part
i love cider by the way
yeah so first of all everybody love
cider
it's it's a combination of few stuff
that
my co-founder and i thought about so
first of all it's a five-letter catchy
name um
second it's uh it's
close to cyber and insider but also our
main domain that we are tackling is the
ci
so we're beginning off
so this is the the beginning of our name
so it's let's say it's a combination of
few elements uh
that help us to take the decision to use
the cider
beautiful uh okay so
what is the problem that you've been
observing with your various experiences
you know before we even get to what
cider security is doing what is the
problem in high level that you're seeing
and i imagine that it has something to
do with the pace of security and the
pace of engineering
so the problem today that engineering uh
engineering uh train you can say moves
really fast
and you know they they
the technology the framework that the
the stuff that the uh the
engineering teams are doing is
amazing and they are moving really fast
and security teams are struggling to
keep up with the pace
and in a lot of cases security
are
struggling to to first understand what
they need to do and and when when it's
struggling to implement security and
they are struggling to
to uh uh
uh to to adjust
to new technologies to new frameworks
and on top of that
uh the engineering domain uh became um
area where adversaries are more and more
focused
on on that we see in the last year
numerous
attacks aiming for that area from
solarwinds to cod cove dependency
confusion and just recently uh you know
the the attack on npm and and the core
and rca uh packages
uh and
and both those uh
uh changes
and and and and and
issues
uh uh require from the security team to
think in a different way and to to build
something that will allow
engineering to keep up with their pace
to move fast you don't want to slow down
engineering engineering need to move
fast they need to develop they need to
to
and and they need to develop as fast as
possible to support the needs of their
company
but on the other end
you want to allow security
to be able to to add the security layers
without interfering that job but
the adding just adding a layer is just
one thing you need to add the accurate
layer you need to add the the relevant
layer you need to make it uh
a guardrail
for the developers and not gates
for them
right okay so i'm hearing two shifts the
first shift that is happening
security is becoming a more prominent
issue we're adding an an additional
an additional you know sort of a
bottleneck and within an organization in
order to be able to deploy the the
software quickly and that is a growing
concern as we've seen and you have
articulated in in the in the you know
most recent years and i and and i i'm
with you and the fact that it's just
going to get more and more dramatic in
in the coming years and then the
addition and then you're saying okay
well how can we actually you know reduce
this bottleneck while maintaining the
accuracy so my question to you guys is
it more of a question of professionalism
in the organization or is it more of a
question of of of the amount of human
resources you can have is it so is it
quality or quantity
in in how do we solve it
so basically it's a combination but the
issue with quantity the the resources
it's it's going to be there for
forever you know the
uh uh the human factor in security teams
is always be will be a barrier you know
you will never be enough you will
always going to be outnumbered
for with the engineers and and the
amount of processors and developers so
trying to solve the number it's not
realistic because you know
not everybody know how to do abstract
it's time to train them it's time to to
understand
and also uh
the other side that when you have an
obstacle or
deaf cyclops
security engineering person
uh uh you need to make it
uh more professional in what he's doing
and making helping him to to
to do his job in the right manner and to
to assist them in taking the right
decision and to be able to tailor
the relevant solution and to to be able
to add layers of security as part of the
development processes
in the
accurate uh uh in accurate manner in in
a fast manner and and with
the minimum friction to the devops and
engineering team
beautiful
so we understand the problem a huge
problem that is just growing how in the
world are we solving it with cyber
security
so cyber security uh took a a decision
uh to build a unified platform that are
going to to provide a single place
to all the security activities
inside your uh engineering environment
what does it mean it means that we first
and foremost
giving you the understanding of what you
have you can say the asset inventory you
can say the technical dna again we're
just giving you the understanding of
this is what you have this is the
processes this is what is moving inside
your environment this is how the
development environment looks like and
and on top of that
building
all the relevant security layers that we
have inside the platform from uh
protecting the environment and and the
ability to tailor uh the relevant uh
security engines as part of it and and
you know in understanding what is
happening there and if something is
bypassing your environment but
everything is unified
on a single place in a single place in a
single connection without the need to
integrate
five six seven different solutions to to
get
or to try to get a a
a decent program an upset program
how do you even start a company like
this so where do you even begin do you
begin with with signing up you know
potential partners that will give you
the validation because essentially you
only know how good you are once you've
integrated into the ci cd processes
you're integrated into the sprints and
you're watching how you're reducing the
toll on the security teams
so
um
you know because my partner and i came
from the trenches you can say we came
with a lot of understanding of the pain
so once we started to go into companies
talk about their pain
it's like was an immediate understanding
of the pain so we first
reach out to many companies that
basically
every company feel this uh pain uh to to
start the partnership to start the
design partner we assemble the three
design partner
uh that join us at the beginning of the
journey
and
you know we started to build with them
the product and and understanding what
is more important for them and so on
and
and now we are
in in different level and very easily
once we are uh
uh uh
uh
finished you can say the the the
development of the mvp immediately
managed to onboard many many uh
companies we already uh
around 30 different uh customers as well
continue to grow
incredible so what keeps you up at night
guy you know if you're looking at where
you are now or where you're going you
know what's bothering you at night
before you go to sleep
um
beside the baby that is crying
so
i i think that eventually
what's keeping up that night is the
employees uh eventually the
understanding that we have already 45
employees
and they are counting
on me and my partner
to to
to to understand that we are doing the
right uh decision
and and you know it's a different
completely different uh
weight on your shoulder and the fact
that you know
thinking about
how do i make sure that you know they
they they
you know it sounds like very uh
something that
in this ecosystem can't happen but
eventually make sure that they can bring
food to their
home on a monthly basis and everything
is okay and the companies
continue to move forward and you know
and everything is uh and the the the
lights are up and and and
you know it's it's it's bothering me to
on a daily basis to make sure that
you know
they have everything
that they need
and we are taking the right decision uh
uh to support it
so now i want to ask on the you know 180
degrees of this question so not what
bothers you now but you know what gets
you excited because i see that you know
and i can feel the energy from your
voice that the way that you're talking
about the security and absec world and
that it's really it's a pain point that
you're that you're working on and you
know what what is most exciting for you
about the journey and is that excitement
different than what you've experienced
before now that you're an entrepreneur
uh
yeah i think it's um
if before that you know i change
one company world uh yeah one company at
the time
now uh i'm excited about the fact that
we're building something that can
uh change a complete ecosystem and will
impact
thousands of thousands of companies that
will impact eventually their user which
are billions of users out there that
will get
more secure products
at the end of the day
eventually at the end of the day
we are making sure that
uh the end user will get a more secure
product
and and this is what excites me that the
understanding that
if we would do right and and if we would
walk
uh in the right way and we do the right
things inside of the product the impact
can impact billions of people out there
because we're now working with companies
that are serving
hundreds of millions of uh people uh
from different uh countries
i love it if if you're thinking about
the the way you're getting inspiration
right now see with 30 customers the
product is still you know it's a it's a
never-ending changing cycle and
where you know where are you in terms of
the inspiration that you're getting you
know do you are you you know is it from
a specific place that you're that you're
looking at or you you know are there
different sources that you're using to
enrich yourself and become a better
thinker and a better leader
um
so uh i think that i i i can get i'm
getting inspiration for many and many
places one inspiration is that i'm
getting this from you know from my
previous uh
guy from guys cecil
trying to help
guy and try to understand what will
motivate guy what would make sure that
guy will be happy
about this product
because eventually i'm reselling to
security teams and cesars and the elder
uh um
i get inspiration from many uh
amazing security teams that are doing
crazy stuff for example uh netflix
uh that they
i
also in my position as the cso and the
apps flyer i got i drew a lot of
inspiration from watching what they're
doing and
how they thinking about engineering and
security
um
so this is the team uh that i'm getting
inspiration from uh and and
and there are some
amazing managers that i'm getting
inspiration about
how big do you want to dream how where
do you want to be
how to to manage the team and and and
where do you want to be
at the end of the year in two years and
and and few years from now incredible
guy i really want to thank you thank you
for everything i really appreciate your
time your energy your insights the work
that you're doing best of luck with
cider security and thank you for
spending these 20 minutes with me
thank you so much for your time and
thank you for hosting me it was a real
pleasure for me as well
thank you very much
[Music]